the movie that was made possible due to
leaked test footage the film that movie
critic roger ebert called the best
superhero movie you'd ever seen keep
watching as we rank every non-mcu marvel
movie warning this video contains fast
flashing images viewer discretion is
advised especially for those with
photosensitive epilepsy 2005's man thing
was produced as part of an executive
deal marvel made with artisan
entertainment to produce a number of
films based on their comics thankfully
the dreadful man thing was the only one
made before artisan was acquired by
lionsgate based on the 1970s
supernatural monster comic manthang
tells the story of ted salas a man who
becomes one with a mystical swamp but
the effects were poor the cast was
unimpressive and it failed on basically
every level especially the decision to
turn him from a hero into a horror movie
monster even notorious marvel producer
aviarad was said to have lamented the
foreign production telling wizard
magazine that on seeing the result i
thought
i can't believe this
the 1990 adaptation of marvel's iconic
hero captain america was originally
intended as a big ticket summer
blockbuster announced with a thrilling
theatrical poster instead it was a goofy
cheap looking movie that lacked all the
excitement and action it aspired to on
the positive side the captain america
costume was a pretty faithful adaptation
of cap's glorious red white and blue
uniform little head wings and all it's
also the first time that the character
of the red skull was a result of the
same experiment that created captain
america a concept reused in the mcu
version decades later starring matt
salinger who is completely unconvincing
as a strong heroic lead its failure
probably set marvel movies back by
almost a decade
the 1986 film howard the duck had a
decent cast and the right people behind
it but there was little that could save
this disaster of a movie howard is an
awkward anthropomorphic duck from
another world who finds himself
transported to planet earth once in
cleveland howard gets involved with a
young punk rocker named beverly you
think i might find happiness in the
animal kingdom ducky
like they say thou
love strange
while trapped on earth howard becomes
the manager of beverly's band cherry
bomb before scientists reveal that their
new invention is what accidentally
brought him to earth but in an attempt
to send howard back they bring the
villainous dark overlord to earth too
and that premise makes little sense to
you you're not alone as it was a flop
with critics audiences and at the box
office a spin-off of 2003's daredevil
the 2005 disaster electro was a starring
vehicle for jennifer garner that was
somehow greenlit despite the previous
film's support reception back from the
dead in a revealing red corset elektra
now acts as an assassin for hire with
new superpowers that include
precognition and the ability to
resurrect the dead no we're not joking
despite a strong cast and a big budget
hollywood just hadn't figured out how to
write a female superhero at this point
instead of an exciting action movie we
got a watered-down copy of another bad
superhero movie while elektra is slickly
produced it's borderline unwatchable
with no charms at all
despite terrible reviews the 2007 film
ghost rider nevertheless was a modest
hit grossing more than 200 million
dollars to the producer's credit they
clearly saw that there were problems
with the film so instead of origin ahead
with a sequel straight away they took
their time to craft something with a new
darker grittier more in your face
approach somehow the sequel was even
worse anyway nicholas cage returned his
ghost rider doing battle with the devil
over the soul of a young boy
unfortunately the tone of the film went
from gritty to goofy faster than ghost
rider's hell cycle
hey what if you have to pee while you're
on fire
it's awesome it's like a flamethrower
cage blamed its failure on the studio's
unwillingness to embrace an r rating
roasted by critics even more than the
first movie spirit of vengeance killed
the series for good
the latest entry in sony's spider-man
universe 2022's morbius was a true flop
seeming to prove once again that without
marvel studios help sony has no idea
what to do with their corner of the
marvel universe starring jared leto
morvius tells the story of a scientist
working on a cure for a debilitating
genetic disorder but the cure
inadvertently turns him into a
blood-sucking vampire pursued by the fbi
morbius discovers he's not the only one
who has gained vampiric powers setting
him up for what was surely intended to
be an epic final showdown sadly the
movie was mocked for its lameness and
for being more reminiscent of early
2000s superhero movies than anything
from the mcu it had surprisingly bad
effects hammy acting and a nonsensical
plot perhaps in the years to come we'll
look back on this as an oddity but for
now it seems like a bad omen for sony's
spider-man universe
nicholas cage who'd been circling
superhero roles for years finally found
his franchise in 2007 taking on the role
of johnny blaze a daredevil motorcycle
rider who strikes a deal with the
literal devil to save his father's life
now blaze is cursed to walk the earth as
ghost rider where he battles the demon
blackheart in an attempt to regain his
mortal soul the film boasted a strong
cast but the horror was undercut by a
pg-13 rating ultimately the film failed
to capture the visceral horror and grim
tone of the flame wielding bounty hunter
still it did serviceable numbers at the
box office enough that it enticed the
studio to try again four years later
with predictable results
the third attempt to get the punisher
right on the big screen punisher warzone
is somehow the worst of the three films
that feature marvel's gun-toting
vigilante while the first wasn't enough
punisher and the second was a bit too
tame this one strikes all the wrong
notes with borderline campy action and a
paper-thin plot that doesn't stack up to
even the worst of generic action movies
star ray stevenson does perhaps the most
fateful interpretation of frank castle
to date waging his never-ending one-man
war in an attempt to get revenge for the
death of his family despite being made
after marvel studios had shown them how
to do comic book movies right there is
little to like about this one
one of the most famous unseen movies in
hollywood history the 1994 adaptation of
marvel's the fantastic four was produced
by schlock auteur roger corman made on a
shoestring budget only so the studio
could fulfill a contract and keep the
rights it was never intended to be shown
in theaters though nobody on the
production knew that at the time like
its comic book counterpart it tells the
origin story of four friends who venture
into outer space and are granted
incredible superpowers suiting up is a
superhero team that clash with the metal
suited tyrant doctor doom a stale script
and downright awful effects make it a
chore to sit through but it's clear that
it was made with earnestness by the
filmmakers and especially the cast who
you can tell are putting their heart and
soul into the movie that combined with
the fascinating history of the film and
its place in marvel's ascent to
hollywood dominance make it worth
watching as a curious historical relic
[Music]
the third film in the blade trilogy
couldn't quite match the uniqueness of
the first two as 2004's blade trinity
slipped into farce full of action movie
tropes and with a cast who seem like
they're just going through the motions
save for ryan reynolds who seems to
enjoy hamming it up it all adds up to
one of the most disappointing movies
marvel has ever been involved with even
wesley snipes himself had problems with
the final product resulting in a legal
feud between snipes in the studio snipes
was also dogged for years with
accusations of unprofessional behavior
on set unfortunately trinity marked a
sad end to the promising blade trilogy
and sent snipes out of his fan paper
role on an extremely sour note
by 2004 it had been 15 years since
hollywood had attempted a movie version
of the punisher and it seemed like the
perfect time to finally get it right the
new version starring thomas jane was
based on a comic book run by preacher
creator garth ennis when armageddon
writer turned director jonathan hensley
behind the camera while the punisher is
a compelling depiction of the character
it largely lacks the grim dark tone that
frank castle's story requires it seems
the studio despite the r radian wasn't
ready to head down such a bleak path
even though jane himself became a fan
favorite in the role for his intense
performance the movie disappointed and
led to two reboots over the course of
the next decade the final film in fox's
two-decade-long x-men saga 2019's x-men
dark phoenix sent the franchise out on a
low note wasting a perfectly good cast
the film tells the story of the dark
phoenix which had been told already in
the 2006 film x-men 3 the last stand in
this version the x-men head into space
where telepath gene gray is possessed by
the cosmic phoenix force turned into a
diabolical weapon by a race of alien
planet conquerors the x-men must come
back together to save the world and
their friend rumors swirled that the
film was altered late in development
after the mcu's captain marvel was
announced to avoid comparisons and that
disney's purchase of fox led the studio
to make even more changes to the project
whatever the reason x-men dark phoenix
wasn't just the last proper x-men film
from fox and was also the worst produced
by fox before their merger with disney
and delayed multiple times for a variety
of reasons the new mutants was filmed in
2017 but didn't hit theaters until 2020.
it was a unique film that had more in
common with the supernatural horror hit
stranger things and superhero comic book
adventure films even including one of
that show's many stars the movie
introduced five young mutants mirage
wolf spain cannonball sunspot and magic
as they told their stories to a doctor
held in a secret facility ostensibly for
the purpose of curing them of their
dangerous mutant powers their visions
soon come to life and threaten to kill
them all its fresh concept as the
supernatural thriller gets it some
credit but the much hyped film was a big
disappointment considering how long it
had waited to be seen
more than a decade after the low budget
adaptation for roger corman the
fantastic four got the big budget big
screen treatment they deserved in 2005.
the film had a strong cast and good
special effects and told the story right
from the beginning with the four friends
venturing into space and receiving
incredible powers then grim became the
super strong thing sue's storm could
turn invisible reed richards could
stretch his body to ungodly proportions
and the hot-headed johnny storm could
flame on and shoot fire from his
fingertips together they battled the
villainous doctor doom a former rival of
richards now with his own powers and
bent on destruction the film was
colorful upbeat and adventurous striking
the perfect tone for the comic book
adaptation of marvel's first super team
unfortunately this script left a lot to
be desired getting too hokey in places a
light-hearted rom but didn't deliver the
high-octane comic book action that fans
had come to expect from recent x-men in
spider-man films
it's clever time it's catchy right
the first four ray back into the
live-action spider-burst after their
team up with marvel studios the 2018
action movie venom looked like a return
to form for sony starring tom hardy in
the title role and heading down darker
more mature territory than ever before
the film looked to be a real treat for
comic book fans looking for a better
take on the character than topher
grace's incarnation from spider-man 3. a
big budget barn burner venom lit up the
box office taking in a whopping 856
million dollars during its run full of
just the right amount of over-the-top
action violence and gore the fans have
been craving it was a genuine crowd
pleaser especially hardy's madcap
unhinged performance by looking past
those delights venom simply doesn't have
much to offer in the way of a powerful
or satisfying story turning out to be a
little more than a loud mindless romp we
will be this honest
legless faceless thing won't you rolling
down the street like a third
in the wind
with marvel studios mcu off and running
fox wanted to revive their fantastic
four franchise and capitalize on the
public's hunger for superheroes enter
young indie director josh trank who had
in mind a horror-inspired new take on
marvel's first family for the 2015
reboot he wanted to make a more grounded
realistic and grittier vision that's all
the four young adults discover an
alternate dimension that inadvertently
gives them superpowers including their
friend victor von doom who uses them for
evil in perhaps one of the worst cases
of a studio completely bungling a movie
fox butchered tranq's concept and
re-shot much of the film with a
different director while tranq's darker
grittier version of the fantastic four
may have been misguided we'll never know
what could have been had he actually
been able to see it through as it stands
there's some intriguing ideas and some
compelling drama but the film completely
falls apart in the second half and the
reshoots are terribly obvious thanks to
some bad green screen effects and an
oddly chosen blonde wig for mara's sue
storm
a step up from its predecessor the 2007
sequel fantastic four rise of the silver
surfer added another major marvel
character to the mix the silver surfer
gave the film an exciting new quasi
villain to pair with the returning
doctor doom who seeks to control the
cosmic power wielded by the newly
arrived alien but the silver surfer is
more than a mere foe he arrives as a
harbinger of the world's end as the
herald of his master the being known as
galactus who is on his way to devour the
planet a marked improvement over the
first movie the deepening of the ff lore
served the film well and the cast did
even better work the second time around
but once more the story doesn't come
across as particularly exciting likewise
the changes made to galactus fall
completely flat even for audiences
unfamiliar with the source material it's
not quite a bad film but the rise of the
silver surfer once again feels like a
big wasted opportunity for some of
marvel's best characters stan lee
included
name stanley
yeah uh nice try buddy no no really i'm
stan lee fresh off his turn is jack ryan
in the sum of all fears rising action
star ben affleck don the red cow in
2003's daredevil joining him were
jennifer garner and colin farrell as
antagonist elektra and bullseye
respectively as well as jon favreau is
matt's law partner foggy nelson adapting
both daredevil's origin story as well as
elements from some of the characters
best runs the film seemed to run through
daredevil's greatest hits rather than
tell a single compelling story despite
some good performances and some decent
stunt work the film simply isn't as dark
as it clearly wants to be never fully
embracing the seriousness of the gritty
source material it's adapting thankfully
an extended director's cut helped smooth
out its rough edges but it still didn't
do justice to the character's rich comic
book adventures like the punisher it
would be rebooted a decade later with a
much more faithful netflix series
1989's a punisher was the first
adaptation of the character for the
screen starring rocky fourville and
dolph lundgren it tells the story of
frank castle a former police detective
who was thought dead in the mafia hit
that killed his family bitter resentful
and full of bloodthirsty rage castle
makes it his personal mission to strike
back against the city's biggest
criminals known to the underworld as the
punisher he has done serious damage to a
number of crime families and now has his
sights set on the yakuza the japanese
criminal enterprise that's infiltrated
new york though the film is not the most
faithful adaptation of the character it
operates more as an average action film
for its day and while fans may have
wanted something dark and violent the
movie is bleak and grim to the point of
being depressing lundgren is a
satisfying punisher in places but the
film was mostly let down by a cliched
story and lame action scenes little of
it lives up to what audiences had come
to expect from other better revenge
films in the 80s as a relic of an older
time though it's become a cult favorite
it may be a surprise for some but the
2016 mcu entry doctor strange wasn't the
first time marvel took a stab at a film
based on the sorcerer supreme way back
in 1978 dr strange aired on american tv
screens as an event film in prime time
starring peter hooton and jessica walter
the film follows dr steven strange from
his humble beginnings to his training as
master of the mystic arts the film takes
quite a few liberties from the
character's comic book origin so in this
version strange is a psychiatrist
working with a troubled young woman who
is under the influence of the medieval
spellcaster morgan le fay in the process
of trying to help her strange ends up
becoming the sorcerer's supreme to face
down lefey though certainly a flawed
film if you can look past the dated
production and the notable differences
from the comics doctor strange is a
lightweight fantasy adventure that
should delight die hard fans of marvel's
resident wizard following three hit
x-men films where hugh jackman proved a
standout as the hero wolverine fox
finally gave him his own film 2010's
x-men origins wolverine took a trip back
in time to show how logan became the
famed mutant with unbreakable claws
your country needs you
i'm canadian
it turns out he and his brother were
born in 19th century canada and fought
numerous wars together before being
recruited to a secret government
organization when victor goes rogue and
kills logan's only love logan undergoes
the experimental procedure that bonds
the unbreakable alloy adamantium to his
bones in order to hunt down his brother
x-men origins wolverine has plenty of
thrilling action set pieces and some
intriguing new characters but
disappoints with lackluster cgi a clumsy
story and confusing connections to the
larger x-men universe it's also infamous
for co-starring ryan reynolds first
appearance as wade wilson later known as
deadpool and totally butchering the
character something they even made fun
of in the deadpool 2 post credits scene
even if the first venom film in 2016
wasn't loved by critics its massive haul
at the box office was more than enough
to earn it a sequel woody harrelson had
already teased the villain carnage and
with tom hardy back on board and andy
circus coming on board to direct it had
all the ingredients for another smash
success and it was a hit thanks to a
bigger and crazier villain bigger stakes
and bigger and bloodier action in the
film reporter eddie brock gets an
interview with convicted serial killer
cletus cassidy and unwittingly gives him
a portion of the venom symbiote merged
with the deranged madman they become the
homicidal supervillain carnage and it's
up to brock and his venom personality to
work together to stop his reign of
terror let there be carnage as mostly
mindless chaos and violence and in that
it succeeds but its thin characters and
a thinner unimaginative story make it a
shorter sit through if you're looking
for anything more time to die that's the
spirit i mean us
we are going to die
coming out just two years after the
success of x-men days of future past
2016's x-men apocalypse went further
down the rabbit hole of x-men lore
introducing the ancient being known as
apocalypse who was said to have been
mankind's first mutant facing a
diabolical threat unlike anything
they've seen before the x-men regroup to
stop apocalypse and his four horsemen
though it gets credit for its ambitious
premise apocalypse was a big letdown
instead of the gripping dramatic story
and engaging characters we got in days
of future past its sequel devolves into
straight action schlock and an excellent
cast is wasted ultimately it's a film
that looks great on paper but doesn't
translate to the screen but another
memorable slow motion quicksilver set
piece helps bump this one up a little
higher on this list
the sequel to the reboot the amazing
spider-man andrew garfield's return as
the web slinger in 2014 was in some ways
an improvement over the first
installment spidey is back in action
saving new york city from evil doers
including an emerging threat known as
electro a down on his luck technician
who's granted superpowers when he falls
into a tank of electric eels and when
his best friend harry osborne becomes a
twisted goblin baddie himself parker
uncovers a vast conspiracy out of the
oscorp labs while it certainly looked
better than the first one the sloppy
mishmash plot brought the whole endeavor
crashing down there's quite a few bright
spots in the movie but not enough to
keep it afloat and despite pulling in
some serious box office numbers it was a
disappointment for the studio one silver
lining though its lack of success
partially led to sony's deal with marvel
and the introduction of tom holland in
the mcu as a newly rebooted wall crawler
for the hulk's 2003 big screen debut
universal and marvel went outside the
box and tapped director ang lee to bring
bruce banner and his big green alter ego
to life following the accident that
turns him into the hulk banner finds
himself hunted by the us military all
while contending with his father who now
possesses powerful abilities of his own
angley brought a certain seriousness to
the project attempting to turn the story
of bruce banner into something of a
shakespearean tragedy when it works it
really works and the film's stellar cast
do some excellent work but lee's
insistence on turning the visuals into a
comic book farce lets the film down with
odd cgi that turned the towering hulk
into a foolish cartoon character in
parts meanwhile a clunky final act in a
murky battle with a nebulous villain
leaves much to be desired
1998's blade set the standard for
fast-paced kung fu comic book action in
america complete with black leather
jackets and a rapid-fire techno-driven
soundtrack the story begins with
half-human half-vampire blade played by
wesley snipes serving as a vampire
hunting mercenary along with his
sidekick whistler the hero tracks and
hunts the newly emerged vampire leader
deacon frost who seeks to eliminate the
human race by summoning forth an ancient
evil terribly dated today it was an
impressive rollercoaster ride at the
time the influence of the film cannot be
overstated either as it was more than
just a trendsetter and tone and style
for late 90s action movies that would
follow blade also proved to hollywood
that a relatively obscure superhero with
a charismatic star and some clever
fast-paced action could become a big hit
with audiences
when a superhero action movie ends up a
surprise hit you can bet you'll get a
sequel and that's exactly what happened
with blade with a new director in the
form of guillermo del toro blade 2 came
out of the shadows and bit the necks of
audiences everywhere in 2002. like any
good sequel the good got better
including even more impressive action
and a great cast blade 2 one-upped its
predecessor in almost every area but
once again falls victim to some of the
same flaws as the original a thin story
and weak characters make it another
action first movie meant merely to
overwhelm the senses with impressive
fight scenes kung fu choreography and
blazing shootouts which it does
the third in the first x-men movie
trilogy 2006's x-men 3 the last stand
was not up to the standards of the first
two films but still manages to impress
in a few places the film opens with a
clever flashback that utilizes one of
the earliest instances of digital
de-aging it's here we discover that
professor x and magneto have been
manipulating telepath jean grey all her
life in the hopes of keeping her
overwhelming telepathic powers from
destroying herself and everyone around
her flash forward years later and the
government has developed a cure for the
mutant gene in defiance magneto recruits
an army of mutants to fight back and
unleashes the power of jean grey's
phoenix personality despite some strong
new casting choices and some compelling
new ideas thrown into the mix the
threequel was a haphazardly assembled
over-the-top action film its tried to
overstuffed script lacked much of the
heart and soul of the previous movies
hugh jackman's wolverine however remains
as impressive as ever despite acclaimed
director sam raimi reuniting with the
cast of the first two films 2007
spider-man 3 was a low point for the
original spider-man trilogy here peter
parker continues dealing his double life
as a crime-fighting wall crawler while
his best friend harry osborne still
blaming spider-man for the death of his
father suits up as a new goblin and sets
out for revenge meanwhile peter
discovers an alien ooze that grafts
itself to his costume making him more
powerful than ever but also twists him
into a darker unleashed man jeopardizing
his relationship with mary jane and of
course that ooze turns out to be the
symbiote called venom you made me lose
my girl
now i'm gonna make you lose yours
how's that sound
tiger if all of this sounds like a lot
you'd be right and while the movie was
the biggest yet in terms of box office
dollars it's jumbled mess of a plot and
two too many villains holds it back from
greatness thomas hayden church however
is inspired to sandman while the movie
disappoints both he and maguire would
return 15 years later for some
redemption in spider-man no way home
sony forged ahead with a full reboot of
the franchise with 2012's the amazing
spider-man after the plug was pulled on
a sam raimi directed spider-man 4
british actor andrew garfield took up
the mantle as the old web head and
rising star emma stone played parker's
high school sweetheart gwen stacy in
this new darker origin story we learned
that the spider bite that gave parker
his powers was no accident and then his
parents thought dead years before may
have been leading a secret double life
after he becomes the amazing spider-man
he clashes with the monstrous lizard who
seeks to turn the entire city into his
own kind though only a marginal step up
from spider-man 3 what really inspired
audiences was the promise it held for
the future of the franchise garfield
proved himself as a different kind of
peter parker and a funnier spider-man
with the backstory of the parkers oscorp
and several other factors this exciting
new world was filled with potential
sadly the sequel would be a huge step
down and the potential would go
unfulfilled
with star hugh jackman back as logan
2013's the wolverine was the self-titled
follow-up to x-men origins wolverine
starting out with a flashback to world
war ii we see logan saving the life of a
japanese man named ichiro in the present
logan is visited by a mysterious mutant
woman named yukio who wants him to come
to japan where ichiro lays dying after
all these years ichiro believes he's
found a way to transfer logan's healing
powers to himself but while in japan
logan is drawn into ichiro's conflict
with the yakuza after they attempt to
kidnap his granddaughter a complex
thriller that finally gives wolverine a
worthy story all his own nods to the
character's comic book adventures in
japan were well served the movie's
biggest flaw is a disjointed sloppy
ending that leans heavily on bad comic
book movie cliches still up until the
hokie final battle the film expertly
injects some pathos into the character's
solo series
for decades fans have been dreaming of a
big budget x-men movie well in 2000 they
got it unlike anything fans had seen
before full of the best comic book
action ever seen mixed with heartfelt
drama x-men proved to be a
groundbreaking comic book movie more
than just a pioneering superhero film it
kick-started the boom and superhero
movies that would follow though it took
quite a bit of leeway with the source
material it got the core of the x-men
right as an allegory for bigotry and
racism it also turned hugh jackman into
a star and put him into the signature
role that he'd played for nearly 20
years it spawned a billion dollar global
franchise and it's not an understatement
to say that the mcu might not have ever
existed without it as it was on x-men
that mcu had kevin feige got his start
as a fledgling producer
ryan reynolds returned to star in 2018's
deadpool 2 and this time he had a bigger
budget and even more wisecracks in his
arsenal the action starts when a
mysterious cybernetic mutant warrior
called cable arrives from the future in
search of a young boy who will one day
become a terrible villain and then
predictably everything goes straight to
hell when deadpool gets involved every
bit as sharp wild and hilarious as the
first film deadpool 2 expands on the
adventure with more characters and even
better villains new characters domino
and cable shined and reynolds once more
proved why he and he alone was born to
play deadpool delivering his trademark
vulgar wit abrasive sarcasm and fourth
wall breaking gags a bigger budget and
more varied action were improvements but
no matter how good the sequel still
couldn't match the freshness of the
unexpected first film still it proved an
even bigger box office smash easily
securing a third movie in the series
2003's x2 x-men united wasted no time in
showing how he could top the original
x-men film an impressive opening action
sequence saw new mutant nightcrawler
using his fantastic teleporting powers
to infiltrate the white house in an
attempt to assassinate the u.s president
thankfully he fails and the x-men taken
the blue-skinned outcast mutant who had
been brainwashed but now the government
is afraid of them military commandos
invade the x-men's home leading to one
of the best sequences in all the x-men
films with even bigger action and more
spectacular special effects plus new
team members like iceman and a renewed
focus on the origins of hugh jackman's
wolverine x2 x-men united impressed with
a bigger box office haul and even better
reviews the film was and remains a clear
favorite among critics and audiences
alike
part reboot part prequel to the x-men
franchise director matthew vaughn
brought the series back with an all-new
cast with the 2011 film x-men first
class starring james mcavoy and michael
fassbender as younger versions of
professor x and magneto the film
chronicled their early friendship turned
rivalry culminating in an epic showdown
on land c and the air a smaller more
modest film than the earlier x movies
first class refrained from the
over-the-top action for a strong
character-driven story led by its
exceptional cast the result was a
critically well-received hit that led to
four sequels and reinvigorated the
franchise for a whole new generation it
also introduced many audiences to
jennifer lawrence who like jackman
before her leverage the x-men movies and
to superstardom the 2016 film deadpool
was stuck in development hell after the
disappointing first appearance for the
character in x-men origins wolverine
years earlier leaked test footage that
was met with thundering applause from
fans forced the studio into production
and a good thing too because it turned
out to be a surprise smash hit in the
highest grossing rated movie ever ryan
reynolds plays devil mate care mercenary
wade wilson who was diagnosed with
terminal cancer volunteering for an
experiment run by a shadowy government
agency wilson becomes deadpool an
unstoppable mutant assassin who's
impossible to kill but when deadpool
breaks free of their control they take
his girlfriend hostage and deadpool has
to turn to the x-men for help past funny
and imaginative it was a groundbreaking
superhero movie that got everyone in the
industry rethinking the possibilities
for r-rated comic book movies
2002 spider-man delivered audiences the
first big-budget live-action adaptation
of the world's famous webslinger and did
it with poise directed by horror icon
sam raimi and boasting an excellent cast
it delivered just the kind of colorful
superhero adventure that audiences
hadn't seen in decades the film told
spider-man's classic origin story high
school student peter parker is bitten by
a genetically engineered spider and
receives incredible powers but when he
fails to prevent the murder of his
beloved uncle ben peter learns well you
know what he learns with great power
comes great responsibility
a true blockbuster it broke records
becoming the first movie to ever earn
more than 100 million dollars on its
opening weekend it led to two sequels
and made maguire the definitive
spider-man for more than a generation
2014's x-men days of future past begins
in a dystopian future where the
government has cracked down on mutants
wolverine is sent back in time where he
must bring together the younger x-men
with her enemies to stop a plot that
will ultimately lead to the near
extermination of all mutants combining
both casts with wolverine leading the
story proved to triumph a popcorn flick
with surprising charm at heart x-men
days of future past is a breezy
effortless action adventure it's several
stunning action sequences including the
introduction of the super speedy mutant
quicksilver made days of future past the
most unforgettable movie in the series
the perfect example of a sequel that
outdoes an already great original 2004's
spider-man 2 brought back the cast and
crew of the previous film hitting the
hero against perhaps the most well-known
of the wall crawler's famous rogues
gallery robotic arm doctor octopus
played by veteran actor alfred molina
doc ock came alive as a charismatic
scientist on an obsessive quest to prove
his revolutionary theories and willing
to kill to do it even more than the
original spider-man 2 set the standard
by which all future superhero comic book
films would be judged molina's sly
devilish doctor octopus became a
blueprint for later villains the baddie
with a misguided quest and sam raimi's
direction and amped up from the prior
film proved comic book films could
embrace a little scariness even noted
critic roger ebert notoriously hard on
comic book films of the day gave the
film four stars saying simply this is
what a superhero movie should be
i gotta tell you spider-man 2 just may
be the best superhero movie i have ever
seen well most superhero films are
bombastic adventures logan by contrast
is a dark sobering drama about an aging
hopeless man looking for meaning in a
not too distant bleak future mutants
have become outlaws and logan is tired
of running but when he comes across a
lost little girl named laura he's forced
to embrace his inner hero once again and
vows to keep her safe in what would be
his final performance in the role hugh
jackman delivers a tour de force as the
eponymous hero logan has a realness and
intensity thanks to its soulful
characters and powerful performances
emotionally resonant and moving in a way
that transcends a superhero comic book
movie genre it's not just the best
non-mcu movie from marvel it may very
well be the best marvel movie ever made
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]